who did that one diddy
did he she counted down the days to the
end of her mother's jail sentence
but gabriela is still waiting for her to
come home
[Music]
and now nazarene's husband richard must
tell their daughter
they may have to wait even longer you
can't
protect your little girl from something
like this but at the same time you want
to try
it it was hard when she was counting
down the days to the end of my
and when she didn't come out and when we
got to the last days we were crossing
off
she was like you know are you sure
mummy's coming home and we clearly
weren't
um and here we are now having to tell
her that
you know maybe it's got a long time to
go nazanin's sentence ended last month
but instead of letting her go
the iranians charged her again and now
have given her another year in jail
and a year-long travel ban prompting
this condemnation from britain's prime
minister
i don't think it's right at all that
nazine should be
sentenced to any more time in in jail i
think that it was wrong i think it's
wrong that she's there
in the in the first place and we'll be
working
very hard to secure uh her release from
iran her ability to return to her family
here in the uk
just as we work for all our our dual
national cases in iran and the
government will not
stop we will redouble our efforts and
we're working i may say with our
uh our american friends on this issue as
well it's not clear if nazanin will be
forced back to jail or face house arrest
at least then she can talk to her family
on the phone
and we keep you know battling
the iranians have made it clear she's
being held effectively as a hostage
until a debt for british tanks paid for
in the 70s but never delivered
is settled she's a pawn in a bigger game
and a family's helpless anguish goes on
they're reserving the right to put it
back in prison for another year
and then to keep her in in iran for a
year longer so it's effectively
another two years we could be looking at
of course it comes in the middle
of all these negotiations between iran
and the west with
in vienna in the nuclear deal it also
comes a few days after the
debt got postponed and which always
brings bad news for us
so there's a lot of other stuff going on
and you know it's clearly a political
signal we're clearly a bargaining chip
in the middle there
iran has raised the stakes whatever the
uk government has tried to bring nazanin
home
has failed a british citizen remains in
a foreign country
held against her will dominick waghorn
sky news